moi je résume commande
une demande de VTC 10 minutes
on va récupérer les passagers et sachant
que le temps d'arriver normalement quand
je m'approche
uber il s'est fait signaler par Hubert
comme quoi le chauffeur arrive
je suis arrivé pendant 10 minutes quand
je suis arrivé j'ai appelé le code j'ai
contacté les clients
après j'ai envoyé un message comme quoi
salut c'est rubis
[Rires]
on peut contacter le client par avion
par l'application en fait voilà et j'ai
envoyé un petit message comme quoi je
suis là et j'ai attendu pendant elle m'a
répondu au bout d'une minute comme quoi
elle arrive c'était sympa ça dans les
dixièmes onzième je sais pas c'est
l'arrondissement
et après au bout de 5 minutes d'attente
elle est pas arrivé vu que il est pas
arrivé maintenant 5 minutes ça fait 15
minutes normalement j'ai démarré la
voiture en partant et je voulais annuler
les courses même ma main était sur
l'écran je me suis démarré donc là la
main sur l'écran oui pour annuler les
courses et là voilà à partir de là quand
je suis démarré je vois des personnes
sortir à l'hôtel deux personnes l'État
avec une jeune angiome
avec des lunettes fumées
et donc et elle m'a appelé uber Iber
j'ai dit oui c'est moi j'ai dit c'est
vous qui avez commandé Hubert elle m'a
sorti oui et après j'ai dit mais madame
vous êtes un petit peu en retard j'ai
failli annuler mais j'ai eu la chance
j'ai pas annulé parce que j'étais sur
l'écran pendant l'annuler en fait
maintenant vu que vous êtes là on peut
partir et quand je dis ça malgré ça il
continue à discuter avec les jeunes
devant l'hôtel d'accord c'est à partir
de là j'ai dit Madame mais s'il vous
plaît on y va parce que là je suis mal
positionné déjà premièrement et je
risque d'avoir une infraction avec
caméra de verbalisation s'il vous plaît
venez on y va à partir de là elle est
venue j'ai ouvert le coffre et j'ai mis
leur sac on est parti au bout de 10
minutes de trajet
elle m'a demandé de faire demi-tour
retourner à l'hôtel qu'elle avait oublié
quelque chose
d'accord pas de problème nous sommes là
pour travailler et vous modifiez bien
l'application vous modifiez l'adresse
qui était juste devant moi j'ai des
possibilités de tourner tout de suite à
ma gauche
j'ai ralenti il y avait un moteur
rouge et m'arrêter pendant ce temps là
qui puisse modifier elle a pas eu le
temps de le faire après jusqu'à quel
effet devient vert j'ai demandé madame
vous l'avez pas fait elle me sort que on
met pas la pression sur moi pourquoi
vous mettez la pression j'ai dit moi
c'est pas par rapport les pressions
madame parce que je voulais tourner tout
de suite à ma gauche avant de continuer
tout droit parce que si je me lance tout
droit et ça va me mener trop loin pour
faire demi-tour là alors que tu suis
tombé c'est pour ça
pour moi sur moi vous êtes qui pour me
parler comme ça j'ai dit mais madame je
vous ai pas parlé mal simplement moi
j'ai demandé que vous puissent faire les
modifications on tourne c'est tout dit
autorise personne à parler comme ça vous
savez qui je suis
reconnu
quand elle vous a dit quand elle vous a
dit vous étiez sur le cul cul
j'ai dit non mais madame j'ai pas besoin
de savoir qui vous gêne moi je suis là
pour faire mon travail et voilà vous
modifiez voilà à demain vous savez qui
je suis je suis quelqu'un de combien de
millions de followers un truc comme ça
c'est je suis de téléréalité
j'ai dit madame je m'en fous de ça je
suis là pour faire mon travail vu que
vous continuez à faire comme ça vous
êtes sorti à l'automne à l'hôtel samedi
excusez-moi pour le retard et maintenant
vous me dites que je vous mettais la
pression maintenant à partir là je vais
annuler les courses je suis pas le seul
conducteur vous prenez un autre Hubert
ou j'ai pas le seul client pour moi si
je continue comme ça j'ai pas envie de
voir le problème on arrête là c'est à
partir de là qu'elle a dit qu'elle sort
pas dans la voiture j'ai tourné j'ai
annulé les courses j'ai demandé
gentiment ça si vous pouvez sortir dans
ma voiture elle a dit qu'elle sort pas à
partir là commence à filmer j'ai dit
faut pas filmer madame je veux pas vous
avez tous les infos s'il y a un problème
vous pouvez faire votre requête auprès
du beurre viens à l'application et vous
avez tous les documents qu'il faut c'est
même si vous voulez déposer plainte pas
de problème j'avais tout alors on va on
va on va la faire rentrer Brahim toi tu
es à la même version bien sûr que si que
Sidi tu le crois sur Paris
alors attends attends on va la faire
rentrer tu nous diras les résultats de
l'enquête il y a deux enquêteries sont
plus ici et
en fait rentrer Rubik's
[Musique]
c'est normal la musique
j'ai rendez-vous avec lui comment ça va
ça va très bien
je suis un peu remontée
on a un grand groupe télégram avec des
chauffeurs VTC qui ont déjà pris en
charge mademoiselle et finalement ça a
toujours été le même comportement donc
il respectueux une voilà des gestes
inappropriés moi c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
donc on écoute on
va pas quand on a ces remontées là on
est obligé voilà de les dire donc après
finalement
c'est ce qui a été dit par plein de
chauffeurs c'est que vous avez un
comportement de stars que il y a des
choses que vous ne supportez pas il faut
rouler moins vite enfin voilà c'est
c'est ce qu'on va remonté d'accord dans
plusieurs chauffeurs ah oui oui sur le
groupe télégram oui donc plusieurs
chauffeurs qui m'ont remonté cette
information Ruby
alors est-ce que vous vous rendez compte
que déjà on est brutalise pas une femme
seule comme ça
est-ce que vous savez qui je suis congés
de followers est-ce que tu as dit ça
alors c'est complètement faux va falloir
arrêter de me diffamer parce que par
contre non parce que me dit famille je
peux vous attaquer pour diffamation
alors non complètement pas absolument
pas
pourtant c'est quelque chose que vous
dites très souvent
on ira pas loin là
dans le domaine on aurait inventé une
phrase vous savez combien j'ai de
followers ça me paraît bizarre
tout simplement
vous m'avez commandé un chauffeur VTC
pour aller pour venir sur TPMP c'est moi
qui paye donc merci pour moi c'est
cadeau il m'a dit la même version hein
mais je la connais je l'ai déjà eu à
faire à elle elle est insupportable sur
moi
[Rires]
en fait j'ai jamais voulu le médiatiser
en fait je me suis sentie en danger donc
du coup la seule chose que j'ai fait en
fait c'est clairement j'ai sorti mon
téléphone parce que j'ai eu peur il me
fallait des preuves déjà donc du coup
est-ce que vous vous rendez compte que
ici on ne brutalise pas une femme seule
parce que clairement vous avez pris le
téléphone
on m'a pris mon téléphone il m'a fait
sortir de force ce monsieur donc le
monsieur a fait sortir de force il a
pris mon téléphone il a jeté mon
téléphone par terre
donc il a pris mon sac à main il a jeté
en pleine rue donc merci normal que je
m'énerve et que oui peut-être que j'ai
été insultante effectivement il y a un
moment où je l'ai insulté mais c'était
parce qu'il avait pris mon téléphone
alors on va voir les images comme ça au
moins le désolé c'est pour vous si pour
vous ça c'est pas brutalisé
on va se bat parce que je suis connu ou
que je suis exposé que ça justifié
à l'école je suis désolé de vous le dire
avant avant l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jamais vous êtes sourds
Gilles
je ne sais pas ce qu'elle fait donc elle
vend l'autre s'en va dans le monde
entier
c'est drôle c'est drôle tu vas dans la
rue tu te balades avec elle tu as pardon
je dis pas
une agression ce qui m'aide il y a deux
choses
le problème c'est que deux choses c'est
toi qui sont béton déjà tu dis c'est pas
parce que je suis connu déjà on s'arrête
t'es pas connu mais si elle est connue
oui
à partir de là qu'elle m'a dit que voilà
comment ça a filmé tout ça là j'ai dit
il faut pas me sortir votre dans votre
caméra madame elle a lancé une live ah
j'ai dit il faut arrêter s'il vous plaît
j'ai même dit gentiment il faut arrêter
de dire la vidéo avec son visage
faut pas me filmer tout ce que je veux
je veux pas de problème je suis là pour
travailler descendez vous prenez une
autre chauffeur et vous prenez mon
téléphone et ça juste
je vais y arriver
tu te laisses parler les gens parce que
les femmes
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête ton
téléphone toi
[Applaudissements]
donc là ce qu'il a énervé si dis-je que
j'ai compris c'est que vous fassiez un
live insta il voulait pas qu'on le voit
vous saviez et donc comme elle vous
saviez que c'était pas du tout pas du
tout vous saviez pas non du tout
vraiment pas du tout du tout d'accord
c'est quelqu'un ici personne je vous
connais vous je vous connaissais je vous
connais tout le monde sur le plateau
voilà voilà mais nous on est connu
[Applaudissements]
dans une vie vous savez qui je suis
désolé
et déjà alors déjà c'est pas crédible
parce que jamais je dirais je suis une
star de télé-réalité j'ai jamais fêté
j'ai pas la téléréalité mais je déteste
qu'on les médias m'assimule à de la
télé-réalité donc déjà on va créer ça on
est sur des animaux
je suis sorti dans la dans ma voiture
j'ai sorti son sac j'ai remis sur
trottoir voilà ah oui donc
c'est là que j'ai raté le téléphone
téléphone est tombé je l'ai pris par
terre d'accord quand je l'ai pris j'ai
dit non j'ai essayé de mettre un terme à
la vidéo voilà je voulais mettre un
terme à la vidéo c'est pour ça que j'ai
pris son téléphone que j'ai pas voulu
donner tant que je mets pas en termes
sur les vidéos d'accord voilà c'est à
partir
les gens s'il te plaît c'est à partir de
là elle est cédé prendre son téléphone
elle m'a mis plusieurs coups et ma soute
tout le monde
même une fois je vous en sortez
je suis pas quelqu'un
on a vérifié si il y a aucun problème
ici
je voulais juste dire quelque chose et
Mathieu absolument parler vous avez pris
votre téléphone d'accord sans le
consentement du chauffeur à l'intérieur
je vous rappelle que c'est son commerce
c'est à dire que si je peux vous filmez
dans le domaine privé je vous rappelle
que c'est l'article 9 du code civil qui
vous interdit de filmer dans un endroit
privé des gens attendez excuse-moi
ensuite je vous rappelle que lui il est
pas censé savoir que vous le filmez vous
prenez votre téléphone vous commencez à
appeler votre communauté on a
l'impression que c'est le drama buzz de
la semaine c'est à dire voilà je vais
faire un truc sur le dos du VTC
maintenant
moi je vous le dis il y a un moment on
voit Sarah fraisou on voit un tel on
vous voit vous c'est toujours la même
phrase le rapport c'est je suis une star
vous ne savez pas qui je suis
excusez-moi vous êtes juste
[Applaudissements]
jamais ces gens-là c'est toi
le moment il y a un moment les choses tu
es une star tant mieux pour toi c'est
bien
tu l'as dit tu l'as pas dit tu peux tu
peux dire c'est pas un problème mais
derrière utiliser cette notoriété pour
dire je risque de vous déconnecter
à quel moment on a le droit de forcer un
client ou une cliente de descendre du
véhicule de force
donc c'est une prestation il est
indépendant si un moment il voit que il
y a il risque d'avoir une situation
conflictuelle
qu'on arrête la prestation mais vous de
quel droit vous dites je reste
là
c'est la vérité excusez-moi mais à quel
moment de quel droit vous dites à un
chauffeur je vous prends un otage je
reste là et faites ce que vous avez à
faire non si vous voulez éviter une
situation conflictuelle d'un autre
humeur si vous sentez que vous avez dit
vous êtes vous concrétisez vous dites
ouais mais je me suis je me suis senti
en situation
a commencé à être agressif avec moi et
je dois sortir de ton chéri je me suis
trompé c'était simple
c'est pas une agression ce que tu as
vécu les monts ont un sens une agression
c'est quand on se fait frapper il y a
des gens qui sont là
voilà
ce que je vois c'est qu'on a ici deux
personnes sur ce plateau il y a une
personne qui est pas contente d'être là
qui serait mieux en train de bosser qui
est obligé de se justifier qu'il se lève
tôt le matin pour travailler dur et une
autre personne qui est très contente qui
n'a rien d'autre
alors non du tout du tout du tout
mais vous n'avez pas avec la CGT vous
êtes parti à une manifestation pour
faire quoi finalement pour venir faire
votre Story et partir
en train normaliser la violence parce
que moi
vous m'avez portez vous m'avez vous
m'avez forcée à descendre du véhicule
donc physiquement déjà vous m'avez tous
les téléphones par terre oui parce que
vous n'avez cassé mon téléphone par
terre au moment où il a récupéré mon
téléphone et qu'il a cassé par terre il
m'a il m'a arraché du véhicule mais
vraiment comme ça
c'est grave que tu veux
dis la vérité
est-ce que tu es traumatisé est-ce que
ta vie va changer il va peut-être partir
à cause de toi
c'est dégueulasse et d'ailleurs je
précise aussi qu'il voulait pas me
rendre mon téléphone il ne voulait pas
manger
mon téléphone dans sa poche
donc de la différence
quand je me sens pas en sécurité comme
les clients VTC comme les clients quand
vous sentez pas en sécurité annulez vous
annulez les courses alors à partir là
vous faites
pour un client peut faire un Rocket
auprès des hiver pour être rembourser
mais nous quand on n'en sent pas en
sécurité on peut annuler comme les
clients on peut annuler c'est comme ça
les BTS est-ce que vous avez été violent
envers elle
est connecté du tout
il y a des vidéos il y a des vidéos il y
a demandé de sortir c'est ça on voit
clairement
dans ma voiture à partir là que je me
suis vu sur son écran elle est en train
de faire un live c'est là que j'ai pris
son téléphone son téléphone comment vous
avez pris arraché le téléphone comme ça
elle était dans son main je l'ai pris et
pendant ce temps-là les caméras
continent à tourner mais je voulais
mettre un terme à la vidéo en fait parce
que j'ai demandé ne pas me filmer c'est
ce qui est en train de faire c'est ce
que je vais pas vous tirer j'ai regardé
la séquences et je savais j'ai vu le
truc non mais pardon je dirais le
conducteur hier j'ai pris mon beau-frère
juste parce qu'il est avocat je n'aime
pas ton attitude et tout ça juste mon
avocat il m'a dit si les deux ils
attaquent c'est ce monsieur qui a perdu
pour une raison très simple
vous auriez dû faire c'est appeler la
police mais à partir du moment où vous
arrachez quelque chose un sac que vous
touchez quelqu'un ou que vous arrachez
de propriété privée ou que vous touchez
une personne vous avez perdu le procès
il faut appeler la police seul la police
peut arracher un téléphone peut toucher
quelqu'un ou son téléphone
moi j'ai déposé
plainte pour toi
j'ai déposé plainte après on verra sur
les trains
je voudrais
juste aujourd'hui voilà j'ai l'image de
la fille simplement aujourd'hui il y a
des gens qui m'aiment d'autres qui
m'aiment pas vous voyez c'est pas parce
que aujourd'hui il y en a qui prennent
parti sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que juridiquement parlant vous
avez totalement d'ordre
[Musique]
problème mais vous dites on va se battre
ça veut dire quoi mais vous dites on va
se battre mais vous faites le moment
même une seule fois je vous ai répondu
parce que je suis pas levé comme ça moi
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce que
personne
elle a dit fils de ah d'accord ah
voilà ça se dit chauffeur
S
elle a commandé elle était en retard je
dis mais madame vous êtes en retard ça
fait 5 minutes je vous attends là je
voulais Annuler pour ce même je vais
partir
c'est tout tout ce qui se passe
merci juste Daniel tu veux rager depuis
tout à l'heure là non mais je veux
réagir parce que en fait
plaisir à moi moi c'est juste que
juridiquement parlant vous avez
totalement tort à ce moment là si vous
avez jugé que mon comportement n'était
pas adapté que j'ai mal parlé à ce
moment-là vous appelez la police en fait
vous vous violez pas comme tout ce que
je voulais je vous ai pas violenter tout
ce que je voulais vous sortez dans ma
voiture que vous prenez une autre uber
monsieur
en même temps
vous allez pouvoir vous exprimer ok
alors donc du coup je disais que
juridiquement parlant vous avez
totalement tort si vous avez jugé que
mon comportement n'était pas adapté
alors à ce moment-là vous appelez la
police exactement vous vous me faites
pas sortir de force parce que
il m'a traîné là et il a traîné les
affaires donc voilà et en plus de ça
j'ai dû c'est vrai que c'est un moment
donné il y a un moment donné ça m'a mis
hors de moi c'est vrai que je l'ai
insulté
il voulait pas me rendre le téléphone
alors vous voulez pas le droit alors
maintenant j'aimerais laisser parler
du tout d'accord du tout simplement je
dors
même à la main je peux toucher
totalement non c'est elle qui m'a frappé
merci j'ai même pas tout ça à la main
j'ai juste l'impression téléphone penser
son elle voulait récupérer son téléphone
mais sinon j'ai même pas touché à la
montre je suis pas vous devez insultante
traîné forcé donc si vous connaissez pas
la signification allez voir un
dictionnaire pas quelqu'un
est-ce que je peux vous dire que je peux
vous apprendre beaucoup de choses
pris envers les chauffeurs Hubert je
suis
quand même vous faites les stars vous
payez 12 balles une course
ah non c'est pas toujours
fait une course laisse-moi parler quand
tu fais une course je sais pas 12,15 €,
tu sais ce qui revient dans la poche de
Monsieur il travaille dur il existe des
journées énormément et très longue c'est
la première et toi et toi tu vas lui
faire le foot dans la merde
d'accord
en direct mais regardez votre QI en gros
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
abrutis en fait
je suis désolé pour des comptes quand
même il y a des gens qui ont des bonnes
poussent vous permettez comme ça
aujourd'hui de dire ouais tous les VTC
sont à la ramasse tous les vaisseaux
je respecte je sais que c'est un métier
très compliqué c'est c'est un métier
parce que croyez-moi vous avez un gros
problème j'ai toujours
moi j'aime beaucoup rubis mais là j'ai
écouté non mais j'ai écouté les les
vidéos
chauffeur de merde sale fils de un
rubis c'est inacceptable oui c'est vrai
ça c'est impossible donc ça déjà oui il
faut déjà que vous excusiez pour ça
parce que ça on peut pas dire ça à
quelqu'un qui exerce une profession même
si elle bousculade quoi que ce soit même
si mon téléphone non mais ça va
téléphone ça c'est impossible
Jean-Michel non mais les violences rubis
tu peux pas
supportable merci
tout le monde tu prends très rapidement
des tours et comprendre que ça puisse
énerver aussi on t'a pas plus de
violence on t'a pris ton téléphone
démarre et allez on dirait on dirait la
meuf qui était venu à la mode famille
nombreuse
tu peux pas dire que d'avoir pris ton
téléphone certes de force parce que sur
le film mais c'est une violence faite
aux femmes ça peut pas mais non
tu as pas extirper la voiture c'est
parce que tu n'avais plus ton téléphone
que tu es sorti de la voiture on t'a pas
traîné par terre après tu l'as insulté
voilà
j'ai plutôt tendance à vous croire
Monsieur dans ce que vous dites mais
pour autant
qu'en rubis il lui arrive ça si
aujourd'hui on a autour de cette table
une vieille dame
qui n'a pas des ongles longs
[Applaudissements]
personnalité c'est parce que si oui
aussi c'est la double peine pour elle
c'est à dire que non seulement elle a
pas le droit de se faire agresser et que
si elle se fait agresser non mais c'est
pas vraiment une agression c'est genre
tu l'as bien cherché tu parles comme une
merde fils de alors j'en ai vu ma
grand-mère
en priori comme ça parce que c'était
pas bravo
c'est Daniel c'est pas la même hein
la dernière fois on avait Anthony qui
était malvoyant qui avait pris avec son
chien qui a fait une vidéo aussi donc le
lendemain le chauffeur est venu Anthony
ça fait pas du tout que sa vidéo ça
allait générer le renvoie le
licenciement du Berre il a dit qu'il
regrettait que que voilà ils ont tous
on a pas eu du tout la même la même
attitude avec Anthony je suis désolé
donc en fait ton exemple il est pas bon
caméra
moi j'avais défendu über pareil mais on
s'en fout de toi
[Applaudissements]
Géraldine dit un truc vrai on va pas ça
aurait été Anthony là c'était pas le
même débat je suis désolé elle a raison
on n'a pas eu la même attitude et
qu'Anthony je suis désolé les gars là
elle a soulevé un problème qui est vrai
s'il n'a pas du tout été les mêmes quand
c'est Anthony qui s'est passé on était
tous contre le chauffeur
quand on était on était tous contre le
chauffage toute forme de violence envers
que ça soit une femme ou un homme peu
importe parce qu'on parle très souvent
des femmes que ça soit un homme ou une
femme peu importe la violence ne doit
pas exister non attendez enfin
maintenant le terme m'arracher vous
l'employez vous-même moi je vous le dis
clairement il a pris le téléphone il a
cassé il est tombé parce que la violence
vous-même vous la prodiguez à
l'intérieur de son véhicule vous lui
dites NON je sors pas qu'est-ce que vous
allez faire vous avez excusez-moi vous
appelez tout le monde de violence aussi
qui est condamne parce que non
excusez-moi c'est une forme de violette
de la police il est en live
que quelqu'un
il va appeler la police on va mettre
deux heures à venir il va faire quoi
mais lui claque
la prestation excusez-moi
uber d'habitude ils sont très réactifs
hein vous l'avez vu dans l'affaire il
déconnecte mais là pourquoi ils n'ont
pas déconnecté à votre avis parce qu'ils
ont bien vu vous avez des antécédents
avec d'autres VTC
un
historiquement
je vous le dis pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui d'accord votre problème
c'est que vous jouez sur votre notoriété
je suis une star je peux faire ce que je
veux du tout arrêter redescendez sur
terre ce monsieur là il travaille
parce que là monsieur vous me faites
peur vous comprenez que j'ai eu peur
j'étais une femme seule dans votre
véhicule j'ai eu peur
dans la journée
très certainement qui a déclenché la
colère aussi du chauffeur VTC parce qu'à
partir du moment où ils se sont filmés
ils se sent agressé aussi donc c'est ça
aussi qui le fait basculer lui et qui se
dit matin qu'est-ce qui se passe etc et
que du coup votre dispute elle prend un
autre tournant à partir du moment où tu
déclenches le live c'est ça aussi mais
non mais qui appelle la police
la police la police que vous savez tout
qui sont à faire la police en ce moment
ils vont aller pour aller voir Rubik's
Kara qui est en train de Fourier
sans appel à la police arrêter de dire
des conneries donc la police
n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui tout le monde peut
m'arracher mon téléphone
c'est pas pareil votre téléphone vous
l'avez récupéré
le téléphone pour appeler non mais
pourquoi mais vous aviez récupéré votre
téléphone vous la voulez rentrer
bah sur le coup c'était choqué par la
suite
la raison donc c'est un événement donc
ce n'est pas une
agressions
et je voulais vous donner encore une
fois
après
moi ce que je vois aujourd'hui c'est que
toi tu vas continuer de faire tes petits
postes et tes stories
aujourd'hui tu as pas arrivé moi
j'aimerais pas que une de mes abonnés
lui aucune femme que j'ai vécu en fait
est-ce qu'on peut pas tout le monde
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que vous
pouvez pas enrouger l'histoire parce que
franchement c'est une histoire de merde
franchement c'est une histoire
franchement elle est pas dramatique
j'aimerais que Sidi garde son travail
j'aimerais que toi tu vas continuer à
faire tes trucs rubis et ça se passe
très bien pour toi excusez-vous et puis
terminez voilà est-ce que vous
connaissez sa situation parce que vous
connaissez pas lui-même qui a derrière
il a en charge d'une famille vous n'avez
pas son nom son histoire c'est pareil
ça pique ses enfants sa femme et tout ce
qui va aujourd'hui excusez-moi
aujourd'hui ce monsieur là bon je suis
prêt à mettre de l'eau dans mon vin
d'accord tout simplement s'excuser il
est où le truc je comprends pas pourquoi
vous mettez une barrière mais t'es pas
une barrière est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
vous excuser tous les deux et puis comme
ça on passe à autre chose et puis
terminé
si elle a été victime se sent pas elle
se sent pas c'est tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
en tant que VTC et le travail qu'on fait
tous les jours il y a même pas des
semaines de cela quand tu sors il y a
même pas deuxième course il y a une
quelqu'un qui a vomi dans votre voiture
votre soirée est morte que vous rentrez
chez vous vous pouvez pas travailler moi
je pense que si je devais mettre en
colère c'est là que je vais mettre en
colère mais je n'ai pas fait je sais que
ça fait partie de notre travail
tu as oublié de supporter donc je suis
rentré chez moi je suis allé nettoyer ma
voiture j'envoie le fakira uber c'est
tout voilà vous dites désolé de vous et
simplement notre activité se dire voilà
c'est Ruby